[Musique]
cet après-midi le département des
Yvelines organisait métamorphose urbaine
le premier congrès dédié à la
transformation des quartiers
prioritaires l'objectif débattre autour
de l'aménagement et de l'évolution de
ces territoires afin d'améliorer leur
attractivité experts et les locaux
bailleurs et associations étaient réunis
au Phénix de Chanteloup-les-Vignes les
prochaines élections sénatoriales auront
lieu ce dimanche 24 septembre de quoi
s'agit-il ce sont des grands électeurs
c'est-à-dire les mers les conseillers
municipaux départementaux régionaux mais
aussi les parlementaires qui votent 6
sièges sont à pourvoir pour les Yvelines
pour un total de 64 candidats retrouvez
toutes les listes en détail à la fin de
votre 7 8 la circulation risque d'être
compliquée à Élancourt ce dimanche 24
septembre sur la colline compétition de
VTT cross country est organisé en vue
des Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024 pour
sécuriser l'événement des restrictions
de circulation sont prévues comme sur la
rue de Strasbourg et l'avenue Marcel
Dassault des déviations seront mises en
place pour éviter les mentionné toujours
en perspective des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 le
Département soutient 14 athlètes
yvelinois dans leur pratique sportive
parmi ces sportifs Christopher six
cavalier médaillé de bronze aux JO de
Tokyo Rima Ayadi championne du monde de
boxe et Guillaume chaîne médaillé d'or
de judo par équipe si certains sont déjà
qualifiés d'autres devront encore
patienter ce soir ne manquez pas le
retour du 15 de France pour leur
troisième match de Coupe du monde ils
affront la Namibie au stade Vélodrome de
Marseille à 21h objectif terminé premier
de la poule vous pouvez soutenir les
Bleus en direct des Yvelines les villes
de Versailles et Rambouillet vont
retransmettre le match